he's Eric Dickerson hall-of-fame running
back and he works for the Rams vice
president of business development four
times led the league in rushing and six
time Pro Bowl running back thanks for
getting up early and joining us here
great to see ya it's very early for me
you look good you look good but you know
what are you 58 29 yeah you look like
you could give me a couple of carries
let me tell you that I couldn't give you
one care that they had tried to hit me I
would like to receive as I was slide
what but what hurts when you wake up in
the morning uh everything my shoulder I
have a bad shoulder I can't sleep on my
root in my left side my toe when I go to
the bathroom had to go down some stairs
kind of stairs in my bath and you know
going to the bathroom so I have to walk
sideways cuz I can't walk straight man I
don't take everything hurts you I mean
you when you play an NFL for as long as
I dispensing the time that period I
played you beat up and you beat up
pretty good I tell people it's one thing
to watch football on TV but if you went
on the sideline right different just the
sound is alarming in the speed and I
thought if any parent was on the fence
about letting their kid play football I
go just stand on the sidelines and over
don't but it sounds like crashes car
crash it is like car crashes first my
mother hated football she said it got
hate that sport
I suppose go caused you problems later
you should play baseball I was get
baseball player but you know I like
football comes to girls like the
football players back in Texas so that's
why I just love football did you almost
not play football yes matter of fact
back in those days you had to have
someone sign for you to play the play if
you know if you want to play now and I
couldn't play to seventh grade we didn't
have popcorn in my little hometown so
she said I'm not gonna sign you can't
play football I said mom wouldn't know
she said go Ashley guard mother
so my godmother lived about a hundred
yards away so I walked over to her house
and I had you know my paper in my hand
and I see
name is early in la CIMA Merlin can you
sign me to play football she said so
Redmon sighing that's my mother's
nickname and she said no she said you
sure you wanna play that's what I see
yes ma'am okay so she's signed that's
how I got a chance to play football so
late my mother was mad she's like she
signed she's gonna serve you to play me
yeah when did you know you were good
probably when I was um
I made my junior senior in high school
you know I thought I was pretty good now
did I think I was gonna be bad like play
pro football go to college and all that
no I did not I didn't I didn't think
that I was that good but you know it's
funny how people see you and they see
you differently as a guy my own town
outside in my own town cuz I'd quit
football at one point he came he talked
to me his name was James Abernathy and I
won't forget what he said he said Erica
sue right so what do you see in this
town I say nothing saying there's
nothing in this town he said let me tell
you you won the best athletes we've ever
seen in these parts I was a sophomore I
mean and he said you know I'm like
really say yes you should go back to
play football and you know the rest is
kind of history but that's just a longer
story about that side this guy's just
going back to stop playing football
again best game you had in high school
remember their stance state championship
I think they officially said it was 296
my favorites and four touchdowns yeah
and you guys want we won state
championships yeah where were you gonna
go if you didn't go to SMU oh oh you oh
that's easy
I stopped still oh you fainted I'm still
an Oklahoma fan really I didn't go oh
your mom once again my mother once she
wouldn't let me Barry Switzer came to my
house recruited me heavily cuz you know
and what you came to my state
championship game and they came and they
had to you know watch the video and
we're gonna win this tender national
championship and I'm like oh I'm going
I'm committed and I won't kiss she was
really quiet she wasn't saying nothing
so you know the kid gave her to spilling
when they walked out she said uh you're
not going now I'm like mama no you're
not going that why that man's a liar and
I don't trust him
to tell him I couldn't man I'm man I was
so hurt but Marcus Dupree you're a
little bit older than workers yeah so
Marcus would have come after you Nikita
came he came he came out yeah I look at
this career and I think well maybe now
maybe she's right I show you well you
guys had a great team there we had a
great team great team great teammates
great James didn't like my good friend
Craig James and wish faster you were
Craig James Craig James tells a
different story
why 19 is your jersey number you know I
never wanted to be like everybody else
I wanted something hard I really did so
when I took number nine I don't know why
I took 19 I don't wanna take 32 I liked
oj and Jim Brown and I didn't want to
take 34 Walter in a row so I took 19 in
college and I got to the pro line you
know I got do you know how I became
number 29 levitate you the story okay so
I want to be 19 when I got drafted to
the ramp so when I show up to LA they
have I said what number I said I'm a 19
you can't wet 19 it's a quarterback or
receiving them I say okay I swear
numbers you have their 25 29 4532 so I
didn't I say when I'm gonna be 3234 I
said we might take 25 so I took number
25 and you look on draft day I'm holding
up number 25 you can see I'm holding
number 25 so now fly back to Dallas that
night my best friend we still best
friend Charles baby pick me up he said
man what number you take I said I take
25 you say 25 why you take that slow
number that's a slow number me said it
you said you take 19 I told him why I
couldn't take 19 when I told him I knows
it's when you take 29 I'm like oh yeah
so I could not sleep that night I never
looked at number now
I don't know that 29 looks faster than
25 it's a fast looking numbered and now
my favorite not me anyway
so anyway so I when I call back to the
Rams the next day cuz I cannot sleep
that night thinking about that number
that's crazy I know so I say mr. Heward
I need to change my number he said with
Eric you holding up number 25 in LA
Times we can't change num I said you
know what I'm not coming in he said oh
you'll be 29 he's Eric Dickerson Hall of
Fame running back joining us here in the
Rich Eisen studio you look at the the
future of the running back because it's
gonna be hard to find a hall-of-famer as
a wide receiver because the numbers are
so crazy but then the running backs the
numbers are going to be less than
probably what they were with their you
know predecessors here how do we assess
what is a hall-of-famer now with the
running back uh when you look at the guy
and you just say his name and you like
Oh most definitely
I mean is just it's you don't have to go
well let me think I mean I just feel
like an you see a name you know I'm
Frank Gore hall-of-famer um he could be
but I guess he said all right there we
go again this is because he has a law
has a long career that doesn't make you
Hall of Fame not really I don't think I
like Frank to MLA you know you know to
me what would that makes guys all the
families to me is is when they have to
game plan for you yeah they say set the
game plan if you just like hey you let
this guy loose on us he's gonna hurt us
or defensive player or an offensive
player yeah you know and I think of guys
and like I think of Lawrence Taylor I
mean no doubt hall-of-famer and I think
a Walter Payton no doubt Hall of Famer
Jim Brown no doubt hall-of-famer when I
think of my even Dexter Manley maybe
might not know Dexter Mellon Mize he's
my cousin hall-of-famer but he's not in
and gonna cuz he was a guy can thinking
we played the red skins away do not let
him loose help the tackle if you can and
that's how that's how you to me you go
guy make a guy heart not make him guy
off and I'm saying when you say is a
Hall of Fame because of the way you
played against him and if you had the
game plan for him Eli Manning a
hall-of-famer I don't know
I'm not a quarterback I mean some I
can't well but if we're usually but you
know what they're you know they always
go with I always go let him on a Super
Bowl that don't mean nothing I mean
there's guys that played on some bad
teams I mean some really bad teams and
and they didn't win Super Bowls I mean
when we know Dan Marino's a
hall-of-famer but you know he found some
not great team but he'd a made those
teams I mean made the team I mean so you
got a look at that who's the best
defensive player he played against man
it was so many I mean a different eras
different positions you know I played
against Ricky Jackson I mean I think
people on the last how great Ricky
Jackson was I mean hard got a blood and
almost impossible for an officer backed
with his big Xia's Lawrence Taylor
ronnie Lott Kinney easily can easily
broke my hand right here on a Monday
Night Football game I never forgot it
I mean I'm gonna have to see how colors
on my hand I'm like but I mean did
Ronnie but Ronnie luck could put a
little pump sting on you oh yeah Ronnie
got me good at one time he got me really
good yeah I got into it was a play where
I matter thing I have a picture in my
home it's a great-looking shot I'm
jumping over a pile I'm looking like I'm
looking at these guys coming here but
I'm looking at him because he's flying I
mean me and him it just got to a bite
altercation like a couple plays earlier
and I'm trying to get back on the ground
before my feet hit he caught me my real
case but luckily I wore a flak jacket so
when he hit me I got you and I won't
forget Vince Ferragamo called a blessing
no dog you got to throw it he got me
[Laughter]
have any leverage here most definitely
the most damning first of all Zeke is
the best play on the Cowboys football
teams I mean he really is you know you
know the sad thing about this is is that
they tie these running backs up did this
and this is not even Jerry's fault you
hear me said it's not zero so it's not
Zeke's fault this is this bad cba that
they've negotiated with DeMars smith
they've done a horrible horrible job how
can you tie running back up for years
Billy seven years it's been five years
you got the rookie do you have four
years you got an option and you get a
nigga's franchise tag if
Jerry I'm like if he wants to I just
make you play you know in our day they
were just make you play it out and then
then get rid of you I mean there's
nothing guaranteed but you mean you
can't do that because really it's not
fair it's not fair to Zeke it's really
not fair to him I always say look let
him play have him two years in office
and then arbitrated well if he's I
played the contract hey Pam I mean
because in basketball and baseball
they're not to worry about it's funny
how you know that's it all he's got a
hundred million dollars in football you
got a 120 million uh first of all it's
not guaranteed let's get that right and
base Baalak and Mike Trout 400-meter I'm
like nobody says a word because it's
baseball well I look at Zeke situation
and I wonder the value of him
I think DAC needs him Marty Cooper needs
him but that offensive line is great and
and Jerry Jones is not getting any
younger so that's that's the part where
I think he's got leverage that Jerry
knows he's on the clock
to try to win a Super Bowl yeah but but
you know that the team is better with
Zeke trust me that what out Zeke that
team is is average I mean the Cowboys
are running football team they run to
set up everything else I mean they
really do take Zeke away I mean but also
if you look at this Eric if you they're
they're rare that they they're a run
first team in today's NFL yeah it feels
like everybody is pass first pass second
and then you know the thing is is that
people always always not know it's not
too runny but running back just to get
you know it's going downhill this this
is their in the NFL he went back to our
day my date it was only four or five top
running backs in the league at one time
maybe six but that's about it
it's still the same thing now if you
have a top back a top running back
you're gonna use it yeah this is you
have Zeke you have Jeff Todd Gurley yes
a Quan Barkley you have lady unbale I
mean those are the titles of the top
guys in the National Football League
there we are
I like the guys San Diego American Court
and I like him you know zeebee angel I
like him a lot
think about now the quarterback position
it's pretty much the same you have four
to five maybe six top quarterbacks the
rest of them are average are you got a
bunch of bums but the quarterback you
gonna pay him because he's the quarter
but it's a bum well we still gotta pay
me the quarter back and make 20 million
25 million dollars and be like like man
what is he looking at me throws the
football but the running back can't do
that I mean that's why I says it's it's
different positions but you have to I
always said they should have a structure
for running back now I was trying to a
quarter bags and Pam different but
guarantee my giving running back that
two-year option three after two years
arbitrators dealing yeah we brought it
up a couple of weeks ago that why not
just have the quarterback is gonna be
separate from the salary cap and also
running backs maybe three years when
they first come into the league just to
be fair to that position because that's
the one I would load up I if you were my
running back and I'm taking you second
overall yeah I'm gonna replace you in
five years you gonna be do pretty much
done in five years yeah I'm right you
are I mean let you fortunate you might
place six seven no nets on that same
football team in think about my first
year I think I cared about 380 times and
I'm a rookie the next year I cared at
400 four times I mean you know you only
have so many carries we have so many I
care you see I only have so many cares
and you know the thing is is you know
people always talk about you know the
spoiled after leases let me tell you
something there's no such thing trust me
when you if I could put you in this body
unless you try to maneuver around and
after playing in the National Football
League people say oh you like you could
play and I am so beat the hell up
I mean really bad I mean and you just
don't know I mean I could tell you then
after my friend when I retire them
football for almost two years I had to
sleep sitting up in a chair like this I
couldn't lay down cuz my neck my back to
sleep in the sitting up position it's
horrible but see people don't know that
you know they think the money the money
and now they'll say oh you know you you
knew what she was getting yourself into
how do you know you can just set here 21
years old back in 1983 I mean even now
21 year old don't know what they get
into seven do and 2019 so I mean it's
just it's different if I gave you a
mulligan but way smaller football and I
think I still take football you did all
right I'm gonna tell you something you
know people always ask the question you
know
and better yet I give you an exam not
example what happened we were dear that
we did a thing it's Super Bowl and they
asked it was five of us on the panel
Hall of Fame guys dance to all the guys
you know what what is your passion you
know what is your passion now blah blah
blah you know your passion guys you know
they gave and good answer something so
maybe had a passion for word you know I
would think some guys their political
answers but and they say you know every
what is your passion I said I'm just
gonna be honest with you I said to me
I've done things outside of football
that you know good you don't make money
and all that kind of stuff I say but as
a passion
nothing has replaced playing football
nothing
I don't care what I've done in my life
when I go back to when I started and
coming into pros I love that sports so
much I mean I can I just love one to
practice I love the smell of the air
when it's football scene you can you
just knew it I just like I just loved
everything about it I mean everything
about football I mean and I think that's
the reason Tom Brady keeps playing
because he just loves it that much and
if you can you do it I mean it's like
being a kid still all over again but it
comes to a point where you know you have
to stop playing him for me you know it
was it was heartbreaking but it is what
it is since you worked for the Rams let
me hit you with a Rams question it's
very rare for a team to go back to the
Super Bowl certainly to win or even go
back after having lost the Super Bowl
what would be the big reason why the
Rams wouldn't go back to the Super Bowl
injuries injuries play a big part of any
football you concerned about Todd Gurley
me I mean Todd was good for the game too
I talked to him before the game and the
night before the game
and I said we got money on one foot
Baba's gonna mine he said we suppose the
money and we didn't run it I mean one
thing about every coach and you know I
love Xiaomi but he's no different any
other coach in the NFL right now they
love throwing the foot interesting thing
like look how smart I am
I mean some plays a template damn you
see it's a great place I mean but
writing the football is not popular I
mean it's not popular you know it takes
time but I'll say four is getting back I
think I think injury plays a injuries
play a big part of it you know in the
continuity with the players but not one
thing I like about our football team is
that they're very close they remind me
of the team and eighties real close-knit
football team but injuries if you if you
go if you don't
banged up you they have a good shot at
going back Jared gone for franchise
quarter-mile I would and I would give
him another year I mean he want to see
another year I want to see another year
yeah I just believe that you know
they're they're too quick to pay these
these could they don't pay the rounded
bear now anyone play the quarterback you
know have one beauty oh we got the
franchise hypothetically if I gave you
one carry and those my four guys here
head to town Kuya what about oh you
wouldn't take off I mean come on why not
to the right he might be leaving a
problem but these two on the left are
not good you would like no part of this
what you see you really wouldn't like
any part of this that you could tell you
can run over you know you could tell he
just got all the talking it's like it's
great to see thank you thank you for
getting up the great Eric Dickerson
joining for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]